TRACE, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WELL, WE RECENTLY TOLD YOU
THAT PRETTY REMARKABLE STORY
OF A YOUNG MAN CALLED CARSON
KING FROM IOWA.
KING RAISED A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CHARITY, FOR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND THE
DES MOINES REGISTER THE
LOCAL NEWSPAPER REWARDED HIM
BY DIGGING INTO HIS PERSONAL
HISTORY ALL THE WAY BACK TO
HIGH SCHOOL DENOUNCING HIM
FOR TWEETS HE MADE SEVEN
YEARS AGO.
FOR THIS, HE WAS PILLARIED
ANHEUSER PUSH WHICH HAD
AGREED TO A PARTNERSHIP WITH
HIM DROPPED HIM.
NOW, IN A FASCINATING CODA
TO THIS STORY.
CALVIN HAS BEEN FIRED
HIMSELF AFTER HE WAS FOUND
TO HAVE OFFENSIVE TWEETS ON
HIS TWITTER TIMELINE AS
WELL.
AMAZING.
DO YOU KNOW WHO STILL THOUGH
AT THE DES MOINES REGISTER
CAROL HUNTER?
SHE IS THE EDITOR WHO MADE
THE CALL TO PUBLISH THE
PIECE AND TO CRUSH CARSON
KING.
SHE APPEARS TO BE COMPLETELY
FINE.
AND TO BE CLEAR, WE ARE NOT
CALLING FOR HER FIRING.
WE JUST THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT WEIRD THAT THE KID GETS
FIRED AND THE PERSON WHO
MAKES THE DECISION GETS TO
STAY.
IS THAT FAIR?
JOE CONCHA WRITES MEDIA FOR
THE HILL.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
JOE, IS THAT FAIR?
>> NO, IT'S NOT FAIR.
THIS ISN'T SOME ROGUE
REPORTER, TUCKER, WHO JUST
WRITES A STORY AND THERE IT
GOES, OUT, PUBLISHED.
THERE IS A VETTING SYSTEM.
AND THE VETTING SYSTEM STARS
WITH
STTH
STARTS WITH THE SENIOR
EDITOR YOU JUST MENTIONED.
SHE HAS A JOB TONIGHT.
BY THE WAY, SHE ONLY PUT OUT
A STATEMENT, AN OP-ED,
BASICALLY EXPLAINING WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE HEAR ABOUT NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS, PUBLICATIONS
DEMANDING TRANSPARENCY FROM
PEOPLE IN POWER THAT THEY
COVER.
I AGREE WITH THAT
COMPLETELY.
BUT, IN THIS CASE, SHE
SHOULD BE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW IN TERMS
OF WHY IS SHE OKAYED IT AND
WHY THIS REPORTER WAS THROWN
UNDER THE BUS BECAUSE HE
VERY EASILY, TUCKER, COULD
HAVE BEEN ON ORDER SAYING
WHY DON'T YOU LOOK INTO HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA HISTORY?
LOOK AS A WRITER AND
REPORTER MYSELF IF AN EDITOR
TELLS YOU TO DO SOMETHING
YOU DO IT.
WHEN YOU ESTIMATE STORY THE
EDITOR CAN EITHER FULL THAT
OUT OR PUT IT IN.
EITHER WAY IT SHOULDN'T BE
COMPLETELY YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY WHILE THE
EDITORS GET AWAY WITH ZERO
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> WELL, THAT DOES SEEM
RIGHT.
HER JUSTIFICATION WAS AND BY
THE WAY BASICALLY ILLITERATE
FOR A NEWSPAPER REPORTER SHE
CAN BARELY WRITE IN ENGLISH
MAYBE IT'S NOT HER FIRST
LANGUAGE.
WE WANTED TO PERFORM A
BACKGROUND CHECK ON THIS
SUBJECT.
JUST SOME KID GIVING MONEY
TO A CHARITY NO.
NEED FOR A BACKGROUND CHECK.
THEY DIDN'T DO A BACKGROUND
CHECK ON THEIR OWN HIRE?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT DO YOU NEED A
BACKGROUND CHECK, BY THE
WAY?
IT'S COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT
TO THE STORY.
HE RAISED MORE THAN
$1.7 MILLION.
AND, YEAH, I THINK WE HAVE
TO START DOING THAT NOW.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, TUCKER,
I THINK THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM STARTING AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL AND EVEN JUNIOR
HIGH SHOULD START AND I'M
COMPLETELY 100 PERCENT
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS IN THEIR
CURRICULUM A COURSE THAT
SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOCIAL MEDIA BEHAVIOR AND
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE, GUESS
WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE DOING
NOW?
THEY USED TO HIRE COMPANIES
TO DO BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THEY DON'T THAT ANYMORE.
THEY CHECK YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA
FEEDS, YOUR TWITTER, YOU ARE
INSTAGRAM AND FACEBOOK.
ONE INAPPROPRIATE TWEET OR
FACEBOOK POST OR PICTURE AND
THAT CAN ALTER YOUR CAREER
PATH.
AND I DON'T THINK ENOUGH
KIDS, 16 YEARS OLD IN A
PLACE OF CARSON KING WHEN HE
PUT UP THOSE TWEETS OR EVEN
THIS WRITER, AARON CALVIN, I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY
UNDERSTANDS AT THAT AGE THAT
ANYTHING YOU PUT UP IN TO
THE PUBLIC RECORD IS GOING
TO HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
BY THE WAY, THE REPORTER IS
SPEAKING OUT TONIGHT FROM
THE DES MOINES REGISTER WHO
WAS FIRED.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE
WHAT HE SAID.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FEEL
QUITE AS SORRY FOR HIM.
HE TELLS BUZZFEED, TUCKER
AND I QUOTE THIS WHOLE
CAMPAIGN WAS TAKEN UP BY
RIGHT WING IDEALOGUES AND
LARGELY DRIVEN BY THAT
FORCE.
ADDING IT WAS JUST A TASTE
OF WHAT I ASSUME THAT WOMEN
AND JOURNALISTS OF COLOR
SUFFER ALL THE TIME.
I MEAN, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
HE IS MAKING HIMSELF A
VICTIM.
HE IS A VICTIM THAT THE
EDITOR THREW HIM UNDER THE
BUS BUT TO SAY THAT I MEAN,
IT'S HARD TO FEEL SORRY FOR
HIM AT THIS POINT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SAD.
WHO GOES INTO THE NEWSPAPER
BUSINESS NOW?
WE'RE NOT SENDING OUR BEST
INTO THE NEWSPAPER BUSINESS
AS TRUMP WOULD SAY.
UNFORTUNATELY LIVE I USED TO
WORK IN A NEWSPAPER BUT IT'S
TRUE, UNFORTUNATELY.